wir schalten nach moskau zu dem iran von
osten also das was putin ja eben gerade
gesagt hat der dank und das lob an das
militär das ist ja irgendwie äußerst
seltsam und kaum verständlich oder es
ist vielleicht so dass einschwor
einschwören oder
es war besonders an die spezialkräfte
gerichte da gab es einen speziellen
anlass aber es dürfte sehr vielen
menschen auch in russland mittlerweile
wie hohn vorkommen das hat verschiedene
gründe erstens ist tauchen bilder auf
von russischen soldaten die in
gefangenschaft gekommen sind bei den
ukraine und werden von den ukrainern
gefragt ja und von welcher einheit wie
heißen sie und so weiter und dann auch
noch was machen sie hier und die sagen
dann immer ja wir waren bei übungen und
sind irgendwie hier gelandet und das ist
wohl so eine aussage die wir treffen
müssen und dann später sagen die aber
auch wir wussten gar nicht dass in die
ukraine geht also die soldaten selber
waren offenbar zumindest teilweise nicht
gut informiert über das und damit auch
nicht die angehörigen es gibt einige
szenen wo gefangen genommene soldaten
ihre angehörigen ihre eltern anrufen und
sagen ich bin jetzt in gefangenschaft in
der ukraine und die fragen dann wo bist
du in der ukraine und auch in russland
macht sich zunehmend widerstand
bemerkbar auch schon abgeordnete oder
vertreter von lokalen städten und
gemeinden schreiben offene briefe wie
auch sehr sehr viele unterschiedliche
berufsgruppen mit einem brief an
präsident putin schreiben um zu sagen ja
das ist ja ein echter krieg so haben wir
uns das nicht vorgestellt und sagen sie
uns doch die wahrheit ob das jetzt eine
große masse ist wissen wir noch nicht
für heute nachmittag ist zu einer
demonstration aufgerufen ob sich die
leute wirklich trauen auf die straße zu
gehen angesichts der tatsache dass jeder
der mit einem kleinen schild gegen den
krieg sich in die öffentlichkeit stellt
sofort festgenommen wird das müssen wir
mal abwarten ja also man kann ja sagen
der angriff läuft nicht so wie geplant
für vladimir putin
sonst hätte er sich natürlich auch
solche geschichten dass jetzt die
wahrheit immer mehr herauskommt ersparen
können wenn er so eine art blitzkrieg
geschafft hätte da gibt es ja doch sehr
viel widerstand was wären sie
sie meinen es widerstand aus russland in
einem widerstand in der ukraine was
kriegt man nach sie machen sich an
militärischen widerstand in der ukraine
den gibt es das hat den grund dass die
ukrainischen soldaten sehr motiviert
sind sie kämpfen um die unabhängigkeit
ihres landes und nicht nur die
ukrainischen soldaten sondern die
gesamte bevölkerung und ich bin mir
nicht sicher ob die
geheimdienstinformationen die man im
kreml hat so schlecht sind oder ob man
einfach so seine eigenen propaganda
erlegen ist das weite teile der
ukrainischen bevölkerung immer noch pro
russland eingestellt seien selbst in den
russischsprachigen gebieten im osten der
ukraine wo wir gerade vor ein paar
wochen noch waren umzudrehen sind sehr
sehr viele leute in der bevölkerung die
sprechen zwar russisch aber sie wollen
mit russland nichts mehr zu tun haben
nachdem sie acht jahre diesen krieg
erlebt haben der gerade im osten des
landes präsent ist ich rede jetzt nicht
von den besetzten gebieten sondern von
den gebieten die von der ukrainischen
armee kontrolliert waren bis zu diesem
einmarsch und vielleicht hat man sich da
verschätzt auf jeden fall ist es so die
ukraine spricht von dreieinhalb tausend
getöteten russischen soldaten das mag
ein bisschen kriegspropaganda auch sein
aber auf bildern die man sich anschauen
kann im netz die einen überblick geben
weil es einfach zahlreiche videos gibt
die örtliche anwohner posten sieht man
so viele ausgebrannte zerstörte
militärfahrzeuge die mit diesem
taktischen symbol z was alle russischen
fahrzeuge die in die ukraine von
bestimmten seiten einmarschiert sind
haben dass man sich gar nicht vorstellen
also dass das sehr realistisch klingt
dass russland da hohe verluste zu
verzeichnen hat und das hat man das weiß
man sicherlich auch im kreml und
versucht jetzt die taktik ein bisschen
anzupassen wir sehen das weiter neues
militärmaterial in die ukraine geschickt
wird also im moment sieht es überhaupt
nicht so aus als würde man dann
einknicken oder sich zurückziehen es
sind neue panzerkolonnen nach belarus
geschickt worden von dort in richtung
ukrainische grenze und auch an der
anderen ostseite die grenze bei der
stadtberger roth in russland auch dort
sind weiter militärfahrzeuge unterwegs
die nachgeschoben werden können in die
ukraine gerade heute ist auf der anderen
seite liegt die stadt es ist ein angriff
auf angriff erfolgt und es sind
russische truppen in die stadt
eingedrungen wurden auch wieder ein
bisschen zurück geschlagen aber dort
wird gekämpft ja also das wird natürlich
weitergehen und wir hätten jetzt
eigentlich erwartet dass präsident putin
für sich vielleicht aufregt über die
sanktionen aus dem westen die ihren und
doch noch sehr viel schärfer werden als
noch in den vergangenen tagen jetzt wird
swift benutzt als waffe gegen putin und
seine leute aber auch gegen die
staatsbank was erwartet die russen im
allgemeinen leben und im geschäftsleben
also die erzählung in russland ist erst
mal eine ganz andere die erzählung ist
es gibt keinen krieg es gibt nur eine
begrenzte militäroperationen im osten
der ukraine in kiew wird überhaupt nicht
gekämpft und so langsam fangen die
russen jetzt an aufzuwachen auch weil
sie jetzt große panik haben dass diese
sanktionen sich wirklich auswirken man
merkt es schon ich war gestern auf der
suche nach einem geldautomaten der wir
noch geld gibt das war gar nicht so
einfach man kriegt kaum noch geld weil
aufgrund der unsicherheit die russen
versuchen erstmal bargeld zu bekommen
auch verschiedene kartensysteme apple
per google cache funktionieren schon
nicht mehr weil viele über diese
betroffenen banken abgewickelt werden
und das merken die russen und spätestens
morgen wenn dann wieder werktag ist und
an der russischen börse vermutlich der
handel eingestellt werden muss weil es
ein weil so große kursrutsche erwartet
werden dann dürfte das richtig
einschlagen große panik gibt es vor
allen dingen bei den russen die im
bereich import export arbeiten die
befürchten einfach dass sie jetzt ihre
jobs verlieren könnten und das mag ein
sehr großes problem werden wir haben das
ja auch aus brüssel gehört man weiß gar
nicht so ganz genau wie diese sanktionen
tatsächlich wirken werden die swift
sanktionen weil es da so wenig
erfahrungswerte gibt die russen haben
aber große sorge dass es sie treffen
kann und die frage ist nur ob sich das
dann wie vom westen erhofft auswirkt
dass sie am ende auf die straße gehen um
zu protestieren gegen den machthaber im
kreml der aber bisher keine anzeichen
zeigt einzulenken ja also es gibt ja die
informationen
sollten des kreml ist dass man sehr
viele devisen eingelagert hat aber
irgendwann sind die ja auch zu ende ist
das eine das andere ist das wirft
natürlich auch die staatsbank betreffen
wird und das wird wohl das
empfindlichere instrument sein der
stützungskäufe beispielsweise werden
dann ja echt schwierig um den rubel
aufzufangen der wird ja sicherlich unter
druck geraten
ja und am ende besteht zu befürchten
dass das eben die russin trifft trifft
die normale bevölkerung weil die
regierung hier das haben wir leider in
den vergangenen jahren erlebt eine
politik verfolgt die stärke auf
militärische größe ausgerichtet ist als
auf das wohlergehen der eigenen
bevölkerung dort wird relativ wenig
investiert außer vielleicht in großen
zentren wie moskau oder st petersburg
aber gerade auf dem land ist russland ja
ein extrem armes land und wenn dann noch
die währung unter druck gerät viele
dinge teurer werden es gab jetzt schon
die meldung dass elektronikprodukte um
30 prozent im preis angehoben werden das
wird für die bevölkerung ein großes
problem ganz kurz nachdem er von außen
zum schluss die luftraumsperrungen
behindern die die russen schon oder ist
das relativ marginal
also wegen corona konnten die meisten
russen sowieso gerade nicht nach europa
reisen weil europa für russen immer noch
keiner neuen visa ausgibt deswegen so
ganz praktisch ändert sich glaube ich
kurzfristig etwas für alle die
geschäftliche gründe hatten aber für
touristische reisen gab es eben keine
visa aber es ist natürlich auch ein auch
für die bevölkerung hier die gewohnt war
früher mal für ein wochenende nach
berlin zu jetten ist das ein sehr
verheerendes signal und viele befürchten
dass jetzt eine lange phase großer
isolation anstehen könnte in russland
dem iran von osten ganz herzlichen dank
nach moskau mit dem frischen
einschätzungen und informationen